set to run across the entirety of Africa
nine miles wide and then 4,700 miles
long is one of the greatest
collaborative projects in human history
the Great Wall of China was built to
stop nomadic Raiders from pillaging
Chinese villages but Africa has its own
encroaching threat and it's not people
it's the desert itself and the only way
to hold it back is trees the millions
and millions of trees in a line
stretching across the entirety of the
African continent it will be the great
green wall of africa antartica which we
don't really think of a desert because
it's called the Sahara is the largest
desert in the world and it's expanding
the United Nation predicts that as soon
as 2025 two-thirds of the farmable
arable land in Africa will be overtaken
by Saharan sands this would be a
catastrophe for a continent that is
already struggling with sustainable farm
land and food availability and in fact
some countries stretching across the the
entirety of the African continent and
they depend enormous ly on their natural
resources on sustainable arable farmland
on fishing stocks it's not exactly that
the Saharan desert is expanding so much
as that the lands that are being used as
farmlands are becoming desert the way
they have decided to combat this desert
a'f ocation they're going to plant and
grow an enormous barrier the landscape
itself will vary depending on where it
is in what country it's running through
and hopefully will be home to a really
diverse set of ecosystems so far it's
off to a relatively small start only 320
miles have actually been planted but
should it be achieved should this swath
of nature be grown across an entire
continent it would be one of the
greatest achievements in human
collaboration and ingenuity it would
true
be a monument for the ages subscribe
here and watch more videos here